do not let them scare you into silence
and do not let them confuse you into a
holding pattern if you don't know what
to do move do something because they're
coming for you anyway story of the day
trending everywhere obviously Roseann
this brings us to a big question about
free speech versus cultural censorship
my question of the day is do you think
Roseanne's actions first off we're a
fireable offense do you think there were
two of color you think maybe she
deserved a slap on the wrist it's really
simple what do you think was warranted
here for those who don't know ABC
cancelled roseanne after this Twitter
rant from Roseann where she compared
valerie jarrett to a cross between the
Muslim Brotherhood and Planet of the
Apes to sound bad
it doesn't found it but in poor taste
yeah exactly it's not completely without
merit at all but then she went on to
walk it back which is the worst thing
you do walking it back with some bogus
excuse saying that it was the ambien
tweeting she was tweeting on ambien
which being said I can sympathize with
because when I'm on lunesta I start
blaming the Jew I don't want to be I
don't work around and it's a lunesta
it's the lunesta a couple of Bud Light
limes all of a sudden I'm not into it
but I can't against slavery but so
here's here's the point here I do think
listen I think she was I think was just
a very thoughtless tweet I don't think
it obviously it doesn't matter if you
think something's funny I didn't think
it's funny but you never want to use
that argument no I just didn't think it
was funny because I thought he was
against everything they hate and sure
enough though this has been and this is
the conversation I think we need to have
at large here MSNBC right away hosted an
everyday racism townhall here are the
highlights canceling one of its biggest
shows after its stars racist tweet and
the more blatant kind like the kind of
racially the Roseanne Barr put on
display well first of all I think we
have to turn it into a teaching moment
friends and followers who come right to
their defense the clouds that are here
to try and bring us back to where this
is normal to take a well educated
beautiful woman like Valerie Jarrett and
equate them with monkeys there's not
acceptable and we cannot tolerate it
derails notice that I'll trouble just
says very obvious things and acts as
though he's rounding a triplet you
comparing somebody to a monkey is not
very nice some would say that to do so
at a dinner conversation would be
impolite also you should not take things
that you have not purchased some people
will call that Steven stealing this is
what the left does regardless of how you
feel about Roseanne they take a tiny
minority or one small example of either
21 or 80 people or a person like
Roseanne they use it to apply the
societal problem as a whole right
Trump's comments prove that misogyny was
alive and well
Harvey Weinstein proves that there's
rape culture some tiny neo-nazi group
and Virginia buys torch tiki torches at
Walgreens and that's proof that Trump's
America is full of Nazis they give huge
media time to nobodies like Richard
Spencer people is give Trayvon Martin
getting shot by police to prove that
their systemic racism they take these
small examples Rosie O'Donnell that rose
it also Rosie and borrow I'm gonna get
letters yeah Roseanne Barr who ran
against Jill Stein who was a crazy
leftist conspiracy theorist who then
decided to support Trump whose son my I
say in a cash grab who knows but it was
an about-face done overnight
all of a sudden tweeted something out
that compared valerie jarrett to a
monkey and that means that racism is a
huge problem we need to have a town hall
trot out all Sharpton is Jackson
available I guess he's not as opposed to
what we do on this shows is very
important I think most of the right does
it say shouldn't say but we really tried
to which is to let the left speak for
themselves
taking the DNC the Bernie Sanders the
Hillary Clinton's the host of MSNBC the
Vox is the John Oliver's and then taking
on their biggest policies and ideas as
opposed to straw meeting it with some
small person this is also profiles that
free speech still exists in the United
States here you get fired right there's
a culture of censorship which we'll get
into tomorrow specifically after a vice
article vice video came out regarding
college bookings with comedian
but in contrast of the UK where Roseanne
could be jailed just like Tommy Robinson
or Meechum Tommy Robinson was supposed
to be in the show this week I think we
might have to have his manager because
he is in jail or in Canada we're
comedians like Mike ward guy Earl Mike
Ward's been on the show a man was
charged with racism by the way for
seeing kung-fu fighting at a karaoke bar
I believe in the UK so this is something
I've said a lot but freedom of speech
does not exist outside of the United
States period it doesn't matter how many
newsroom speeches Jeff Daniels gives and
if the left had their way here in the
United States we would be like these
other countries if you listen again not
to fringe candidates but people who are
the heads of the DNC people who are the
heads of these media enterprises people
who have been given the mantle to carry
for the left if they had their way we
would be like these countries where you
can be jailed for a speech now since
they can't do that without rewriting the
Constitution what the media does it's
the circus it's the torchin it's the
pitchfork mob it's the court of public
opinion with Roseanne Barr one executive
at ABC is a judge during executioner
it's the cultural censorship from the
public boycotts to the soros funded
women's marches to people getting fired
for saying non offensive things which
sometimes happen in this case you might
think okay so the fireable offense but
there have undoubtedly been examples
where there were non fireable offenses
and people were fired to youtube by the
way great example YouTube right here
curating your own subscription and
notification feed so please hit the
notification bill but at this point the
only thing you can do is join mug club
or bookmark the page and check it every
day because YouTube keeps changing the
rules because we're doing well we're
doing well Peterson's doing well ben
shapiro was doing well MSNBC sucks the
young turks said no one wants to watch
them in youtube is trying to create that
culture its cultural censorship the left
creates a circus and this culture of
intimidation and people see it as
censorship in and of itself because as
far as the results what do you end up
with you end it with a monolith and
position in all positions of power this
is what's so crazy this is what when
people talk about it doesn't matter
who's president right when you look at
the actual institutions of power it's so
funny the left tries to talk about
institutionalized discrimination well
let's talk about one of the greatest
institutions in the United States as far
as influence colleges universities you
have a 12 to 1 Democrat to Republican
ratio that's actual registered Democrats
let alone the crazy left is feminists
you end up with every single late night
host leaning left and all
actively endorsing Hillary couldn't look
every single one the one there who
didn't Jimmy Fallon got flack because he
didn't actively insult trouble he was on
the show you end up with networks not
only canceling shows because of granted
bad tweets like Roseanne that's my
opinion but successful ones like Last
Man Standing because of its viewpoint
that one was undeniable oh there's
nothing offensive there was no offensive
tweet they canceled it anyway this is an
excuse they're looking for and the most
egregious example he ended with the
world's largest video platform YouTube
flagrantly disregarding actual recording
law like in our case with South by
Southwest or the the Vermont transgender
Murr the transgender undercover there
advocating hormone blockers a single
party consent state okay that's the law
single party consent means I do not need
your permission to film you especially
at a public event like a town hall or
like a public film festival but YouTube
disregards the actual law because they
want to appease the leftist cultural
Marxist who are by the way the same ones
who abuse a flagging system the same one
who same ones who know that they can
give permission and then take it away
and YouTube will acquiesce to them they
are the ones who abuse these systems
that's why cultural censorship is always
a tool of the left and it just can't be
from me they do and they do it to
control the conversation and I'm gonna
fight I'm convinced that there if a
nuclear holocaust were to erupt today
and we had to rebuild the whole world
sans internet in Hollywood the society
would lean wildly conservative
oh absolutely without that without the
influence that they get to keeping the
bubble absolute answer you cons I mean
you're looking at one of those
conservative generations period a lot of
issues despite all of this despite the
uphill battle so here's the thing yes
businesses can do whatever they want
okay make no mistake these businesses
are able to cancel Rosanna YouTube can
say we don't want any conservatives on
our platform but what these businesses
are doing is trying to use their massive
influence to blatantly usurp the law and
get you so confused as to what's what
that you'll just stay silent so hold on
a second I went to a public I went to a
public gathering and it filmed some
people who were advocating putting
children on hormone blockers doctor Rex
but that was a guy's name that we talked
about on a Rogen show and then it got
removed because the guy said well I
don't really want to be on camera hold
on a second well but but the law is
single party consent law right we have a
lawyer in retainer and they get youtube
says doesn't matter we don't respect the
law so what do they want you to do they
want you to get so confused they wanting
it so free
that you remains and you don't have to
here's something important just like you
don't have to be a cheerleader for
Donald Trump you can just as easily say
I think Rosen's tweet was dumb yeah I
don't think it was a good tweet you know
I can I can understand the situation or
if you want you can say I don't really
care what you tweeted you do have that
opinion too and you can go on your merry
way expressing other opinions you don't
need to be tarred and feathered because
YouTube wants to put you in an algorithm
with some neo-nazi who cares if you
learned nothing if you've learned
nothing else from this show nothing else
do not left let the leftist circus and
the torch mob silence you do not let
them scare you into silence and do not
let them confuse you into a holding
pattern here's some of that we talked
about it's really important so yeah you
look at Roseanne right now they're using
it there's a firing squad out there and
they're trying to set an example going
Hey look all of you better be quiet
looking of other examples like last man
standing there saying hey look all of
you be quiet because you're violating
copyright law on YouTube and that does
happen and those people do have to be
banned unfortunately but they have
people who do obey all the laws and they
say you know what we're looking for a
reason anyway at certain point we're
just gonna ban all of it they are trying
to confuse you do not be silenced
through fear and do not be put into a
holding pattern through confusion if you
don't know what to do move do something
because they're coming for you anyway if
you liked this video subscribe hit the
notification bell or if you want to
continue to enjoy free content support
us at a lot of the credit com /mo club
where you get the full nightly show an
hour every day free along with all of
our friends content if not you don't
wanna do any of those things you're
probably just here you're watching me
seething you came here to hate watch
that being said the internet was created
for people like you